édouard are joining us edie covers the
Cowboys of course for the mothership hi
ed how are you I'm well dan how are you
I'm doing okay the show got nominated
for a Sports Emmy congratulation Thank
You ed thank you I hope I don't
eliminate you from contention with this
next segment no no that would be for
next year we're we're good for this year
all right are we getting closer to
putting an end to the dak Prescott
Willie sign a long-term deal with the
Cowboys well from what I gather talking
to people involved yesterday my sense is
that they wouldn't say that it's close
necessarily but they say that it's not
contentious it'll get done and then in
all likelihood dak at least briefly will
be the highest-paid player in the league
I think Dan won one thing that happened
here of real significance you know dak
spent all of last season playing out the
final year of his rookie contract had
his best statistical season and created
all this leverage for himself but where
he lost a little leverage was this
coronavirus pandemic that prompted the
NFL to cancel the offseason programs
that would have ordinarily started on
April 6 for the Cowboys two weeks ahead
of most others because they have a new
head coach and Mike McCarthy I think
that would have created a real deadline
for the Cowboys to get the deal done
because they weren't going to start the
offseason without their starting
quarterback and now that that's gone
the only real deadline that we know of
that exists at the moment is July 15th
that's the deadline for franchise tag
players to sign multi-year deals with
their current teams I think both sides
hope to get done in advance of that I'm
just saying that they they lost the
pressure that ordinarily would exist
with the start of their offseason
program under Mike McCarthy looming in
just a couple weeks help me if it's the
numbers the dollar amount or the years
with dak Prescott that was the holdout
or maybe it was a combination yeah I
think it is a combination my
understanding is that there's no
agreement at this point on the length of
the contract but I think the issue or
the value of the contract but I do think
the issue of length is very significant
in that you know Prescott news agent
Todd France want four years so they can
negotiate
again soon after the NFL has new money
from the upcoming TV deals and the
Cowboys philosophy has always been that
they want longer contracts so that they
can spread the signing bonus across more
time and limit the players charge to the
cap the first few years like an example
would have been Amari Cooper they signed
him to a five-year contract last week at
a hundred million dollars but as
first-year cap number is only 12 million
the cap number every other year is 22
million so that creates you know first
year flexibility for them in other areas
and then dak Prescott he wants four
years and he can say hey Aaron Rodgers
Jared Goff Carson Wentz Russell Wilson
they all got four-year extensions as
quarterbacks and they had a year
remaining on their contracts I played my
deal out why shouldn't I get the same
thing that they got I played at an
incredibly discounted cost as it is the
sudden retirement of Travis Frederick's
how big a hole is that going be to fill
and does that change Dallas's draft
strategy at all you know the interesting
thing about Travis rhetoric is you know
he missed the entire 2018 season with
that autoimmune disorder en barrei
syndrome and as much as we talked to him
last year he never claimed that he had
returned to the performance level that
he had you know become his routine
before that situation developed in
costume in season and last year he
played Dan more snaps than any other
offensive lineman the Cowboys have that
is going to be a significant loss not
only because of that but he's a very
intelligent guy generally and a really
smart football player and he really
helped make all the line calls relieving
dak of a lot of responsibility in that
regard so I think that's another
motivation for the Cowboys to get this
deal done that whenever there are
allowed to be organized workouts they're
gonna want dak Prescott to take as many
snaps as he could get from you know
three guys I have on the roster Joel Oni
who took over in 2018 a season which by
the way without Travis Frederick got
sacked 56 times second-most of the NFL
last year with Travis Frederick back the
number was in the 20s and so they have
Adam Redman who's a veteran who's taken
substantive a govern played a year at
Penn State as a center and they drafted
him
last year he missed all of last year
with a pectoral issue so they have some
in-house candidates I don't think they
have to spend a high traffic to acquire
a center but yeah that's gonna be a
factor in this - he said Werder NFL
reporter from the mothership joining us
on the program the quarterback move that
you like the most in the offseason the
quarterback moved that I like the most
I got you well you gotta love the bucks
getting Tom Brady you know I covered the
Bucs back in their Warfel years of which
there have been many back in 1991 they
hired Sam Weiss they had Vinny
Testaverde number one overall draft pick
Heisman Trophy winner never came close
to realizing the expectations the
organization had formerly go hire Sam
Weiss who is a quarterback whisperer and
his first mini camp practice you know
none of us could wait in the media to
get Sam's impression of Benny and so we
hustle out to Sam as soon as the first
practice ends and he says I don't know I
thought he was pretty good but listening
to you guys I thought he might come out
walk into the goalpost or something so
so that's the level of expectation that
Tom Brady inherits with the Bucks
franchise as it comes to quarterbacking
I mean they get the greatest player of
all time at that position he's got an
awful lot of weapons and I think it's
interesting Dan that he goes into free
agency for the first time in his career
which he very carefully set up this
opportunity and made his own choice for
the first time in his career and even
though he's 42 years old and is coming
off the worst statistical season in
recent memory I mean by some measures of
his entire career 20-year career in New
England he still commands 25 million
dollars a year so to me that says Bruce
Arians in the box and you know where the
charges were involved the Raiders were
interested those three organizations all
deemed what happened in New England as
more the responsibility of Bill
Belichick failing to put a quality team
around Tom Brady then Tom Brady being a
descending quarterback quarterback move
you didn't like quarterback move I
didn't like I don't know that there is
one yet I love the same three signing
drew Brees I like Teddy Bridgewater
going to the Carolina Panthers
I guess the quarterback move I don't
like is
I don't like that what the Jets did to
say I'm darn of letting Robbie Robbie
Johnson go oh yeah right very Robbie
Anderson go where do you think cam ends
up really hard to say I you know I think
that if you look at it there have been a
lot of situations recently in pre agency
where a quarterback has switched teams
and gone on to start a Super Bowl in
fact nine different quarterbacks have
started a Super Bowl after signing with
a different team in free agency and six
have won the title most recently Nick
Boles and Peyton Manning and Drew Brees
so take that for what it's worth but you
know I think cams problem is part of it
is that people teams have who are
interested can't look give him a
physical and you know he's had shoulder
and foot injuries he's had issues with
accuracy throughout his career he's lost
eight consecutive games and he's
throwing 178 straight passes since his
last touchdown and then there are the
eccentricities of his personality that
are not going to appeal to every coach
you know I mean I think a lot of people
think he's a really good fit for the San
Diego Chargers but you know from my
understanding and my interactions with
people out there they really like Tyrod
Taylor they know he's not a franchise
quarterback but they think he's a
perfect bridge to whoever they might
acquire in that capacity potentially
with the number six overall pick in the
draft in a month yeah that's what I was
going to ask you about with Cam Newton
and Jameis Winston is it about their
football abilities or is it more of
their personality that may have it have
teams shy away you know I don't I think
with Pam it's it's injury it's
personality is you know really the fact
he hasn't performed that in elite level
since he went to the Super Bowl and was
a league MVP in 2015 like there's been
an incredible decline in his performance
level so I think that's the concern with
him you know with Jameis Winston and I
think it is football I think it's the
fact that he's had all of these
different coaches who have been
attracted to as athletic ability and his
throwing ability who think that they can
coach the turnovers out of them and all
of them have failed to do so even a guy
as respected as Bruce Arians you know
ultimately who was early in the season
making excuses and blaming other players
in the offense for interceptions that
Winston was throwing until
they became so historically numerous he
could no longer do anything but hold the
quarterback responsible and decided
obviously to take this unique
opportunity to make a change its
position but you know I covered that
Bucs draft when they took him first
overall in the opinion in the
organization was he's a football savant
in fact I remember the general manager
who's still there Jason light comparing
him to Andrew Luck in terms of memory
recall and being able to explain
formations and defenses you know at the
board but his decision-making really has
been his downfall I mean Lehigh 30 picks
five fumbles basically a hundred and
twelve of the points that the Bucs gave
up last year came after Jameis Winston
turnovers and so to me I think that's
the biggest issue with him and in San
Diego they just had a quarterback who
turned the ball over a thousand times in
Phillip Rivers why would they want
Jameis Winston to be his replacement the
worst GM in the state of Texas is but
you have to see these people so you
can't you can't give your opinion well I
mean I think one organization has gone
through a number of head coaches without
having any significant level of success
and so which GM should not be a GM you
have an owner I think Jerry Jones should
not be the general manager because I
just don't think an owner is going to
hold the general manager responsible and
accountable in the way that they should
when they have both roles so I think I
think Jerry Jones if I could replace one
of the two either Bill O'Brien or Jerry
Jones with a new general manager I think
Jerry has demonstrated that he is the
most replaceable but Bill O'Brien the GM
is gonna get Bill O'Brien the coach
fired well we'll see I mean he he's won
four division titles I know there's a
lot of criticism of them I don't
necessarily agree with the DeAndre
Hopkins trades although I've had people
there explain it to me I still disagree
with it I don't think they got enough in
return I think you have to figure out
ways to work it out with players who are
that talented who aren't a distraction
on the field and I don't think Hopkins
is
ever been a distraction on the field or
disruptive around the team at least as
far as we in the media know and I've
been I've covered several other games
I've never got in that sense I've never
heard that from anybody so but but Bill
O'Brien the coach is one and is often
one that his best quarterback so yeah
III would in in the question you asked
me if I had to answer it I would say
Jerry Jones overtime has done a worse
job as a general manager then Bill
O'Brien has in a brief space of time but
there could ultimately be some
competition for that thank you and have
a good weekend stay safe and we
appreciate your time as always thanks
for saving your best question to last
that's Edward ur from the mothership